the Turkish island of gotcha towers over
the Aegean Sea the islands Greek name is
Imbros Dimitri's Yakima's is an ethnic
Greek every morning when he unlocks the
door of the primary school he feels he's
travelling 50 years back in time this is
where he learned to read and write a few
weeks ago he became the school's janitor
a fellow pupil from his school days has
come to visit the news about the newly
opened Greek school spread fast
the men are excited wasn't this the way
to the coal cellar it's like being back
in school it's just like it was back
then until 1923 when the island became
part of Turkey only Greeks lived here
but anchors policies in the mid century
made Greek residents leave by the
thousands for decades the Greek school
in the village of iya Teodor II was
deserted now the Turkish state has let
it reopened and is paying the teachers
this taxi takes all the pupils to school
in the morning there are just four of
them the youngest is five their parents
have returned from Greece and moved back
into their family homes they left long
ago due to the Greek Turkish tensions
but the school has given them new hope
the pupils learn reading writing and
arithmetic in Turkish and Greek the
principal of the school is an ethnic
Greek who has also returned to the
island of her childhood her deputy is a
Turk as is usual in minority schools in
Turkey
four students and three teachers that's
something that needs getting used to but
I believe that it will progress as long
as we do good work and the situation for
young Greek families improves then I'm
sure that more pupils will come to our
little school
for years a Greek Orthodox foundation
fought to have the school reopened it is
seen as a symbol of the Greek
community's determination to survive and
these Greek school kids have already
gotten used to being a tiny minority I
like it I don't want more kids in my
class the village priests would like to
offer Christian religious instruction in
the school but that is not allowed his
father and grandfather were also clerics
in the village but he says past
conflicts should be laid to rest even
back when the congregation hardly
existed no one ever touched the church
not even at the worst of times when
there were fanatics on the other side I
always wanted to return some day no I'm
happy to be back in the 1960s and 70s
Turkish nationalists who blamed Greece
for the Cyprus dispute forced to the
ethnic Greeks to emigrate today the
Turkish state has adopted a more
tolerant stance towards its minorities
expropriated property is being returned
and the right to schooling and minority
languages has been strengthened Ankara
is aiming to improve its image our Prime
Minister is solving these issues like a
truly great statesman we want more
former Greek residents to return to the
island they should be able to do
business here again Greece is suffering
from a serious economic crisis and they
can make a fresh start here let us all
live together peacefully not everyone
here in the Greek village of ayat adore
is convinced that times are changing
despite the reopened school
older residents still recall the bad
times Dmitry's Yakima says he is glad he
spent the past 30 years in Greece in
Germany after the military coup in the
1980s this was a restricted area
you could only enter the island with the
passport people here were cut off from
the outside world and the government
built an open prison in the island
allowing convicts to harass the local
Greeks few people here are willing to
talk about that now
but now Greek life is reviving in Imbros
houses an ayat a Odori have been
renovated there is even a small hotel
Dimitri's yakumo's and the other
returnees are mainly pinning their hopes
in the small village school they see it
as a test of how serious Turkey is about
its new policy toward minorities